[Music]
oh we made it down to Chatham oh I hope
we get a bite staying positive see the
whales the tuna are generally with them
we started to hear them we set up
basically down see of them
tons of bait here that they're feeding
on hopefully the tuna come through this
just deployed our first two baits we'll
see what happens
we won this thing last year by coming
down to Chatham all the time but also by
working with the Hot Tuna so we're going
to continue with that as long as
possible
did you find the whales Bob
yeah I would know they're upwind of us
we can hear them okay
we're right close to Bob he's just right
up the line a little bit from us here
Chris crying like a baby's here
you can't get them walk or a bite and me
and Bob cook on the fat tuna stay in
contact on the radio with more efficient
Chatham anyone that's willing to steam
down here and put in the time and the
effort deserves to be given the right
information I thought we'd be headed
home by now
of course we all do I heard a roommate
that the hard merch is fishing and
chatting which to me is odd you know
he's the one who's been hating on
Chatham he says he's going to stay local
in Gloucester I think it might be BS but
it's too early in the season to stress
about the other boats usually when we're
cooking we hook up so hopefully it
brings us a little luck here
I'd love to bend the rod and get in
early enough so we can get back out here
tomorrow and do it again
There He Is We got a bouncer
hopefully we get a nice one
I haven't heard the wheels for a little
bit huh
no they definitely moved on
smell them
yep we're on 150 seems real seems real
Bob's got him on how deep
150. that's got to be right in front of
his face
good one good one this is why we come
down here get it buddy you know they can
say what they want let us burn the fuel
we want but this is where the fish yeah
what is that
you got it yeah thanks buddy yeah
no full bellies always keeps the crew
happy so when you're in a good mood
usually Hook Fish
foreign
[Music]
I feel like it might be a tuna
personally only because a shark I feel
it would come up a lot faster by now
[Music]
right
just took somebody off the Reel that
time man you never know definitely a
tuna
I'm not sold this is a fish fingers
crossed we can land this thing and uh
head for the barn ready Johnny yep
treating like a tuna every single time
I moved it up a bit
hope it's the right one
we'll see how it goes here
come on go
foreign
[Music]
oh my God what the hell is that about
I can see the glow
yeah that's a chalk
[Music]
oh
well that was a little bit disappointing
ah get back to the drift and hopefully
hook back up
[Music]
we are on Fuego right now let's go
go to Port
forward forward
there he is no no hold on all right
breaks
[Music]
foreign